[Music]
who already have family directors in momentum
in the business world is both
People bullying like a to the bitterest
linus a jump there are already beecher
about the it
it is basically jansen zenith and
personnel who looks knew I will do this
an alpha personality
hereafter and partly responsible for the
charm all of flour the greenhouse and red
chimpanzee politics go much longer
and that is what one at newt gingrich
two the we public anthem to read
and then the bleeding debit the charm
alpha mail became very popular after
that
and in fuck simply the last letsion
the work with us all the time turkish play
and the management of certain candide aids
especialy by man who won the election
and so alpha mailed time has been used
over and over ns some very narrow sen
such as be used in so and cochlea
the innermost darkest
well for that is what after two lee what that
all families about and symbian bacon
he is benefit's insightly into it
chimpanzee society b in bing and jump
there is get to know the bath and cuff tab
cuff the use the distinguished tab
can be case through its icons'
he can go through the bully's
ones who fight and everybody and
terrorizing stage offers him about the
it and winds bankrupt and simon and the
leaders despair
the ones who mediate conflict make sense
step conflict dr control in thief chips
someone is the stress because they are just a
fighter whatever diggle about the
and guys and site you can see that
small role as if I simply go to the poll
village then has been destroyed by and
earthquake or the president will go to a
place that is heard by harry kane
so the console there in sifrol is extremely
important
and the mediation role of or settling
sites and keeping the unity on the group
basically the unify there on the group is a
very important role is and so is me
a leader site the bully's usually and
poorly in the world who haven't
chimpanzees who blew it you can take
game rates apply to the group and i
think there or a last last few years
as far as smooth and grahl family was one of
them in the waal last it before 12
yrs and and brass by who are they
smeels some time can be in power for 12
years is because the group's let the
group like voice and so fat group
hey snowy are between gates challenger
is that they are challenger coming along the
challenges that all formal in this very
good leader
d the event can give him the keepin empower them
will fail democratically mechanically
right there and if it's a boy
then the forcing do this or this
challenger your supporter challenger and such
that's why if such a chimpanzee society
the alpha mail very often i it is me
leader and is a June fire and think
it's always very important if people
we use the position of alpha mail to
bing the stumps, the minister voted the bios
[Music]